Gear for it is,
and I wonder how many wrestlers out there looking at in Ghana and going,
I wonder,
I wonder what would happen if you take that guy down.
No,
the,
I mean,
even me being in the same weight class,
I mean that's,
that's my,
my wife was asking him,
who would you be more terrified to fight before the fight?
You know,
I'm a steward,
I'm going to be 62.
We can get you down to a five that you go on key.
Oh yeah.
But when the Overeem and him where we're facing off,
she's like,
which one would you prefer to fight?
And I was like,
I think Nick Ghana,
I think Francis,
yeah,
well this was before he pays and uh,
Allister into orbit.
But uh,
I,
because he'd take him down to come down and then,
uh,
and then it's your game.
Hopefully Allister's so seasoned and everything else.
He does have some takedown defense and he does have some submissions,
so I've just seen him be more well rounded.
And uh,
so,
but that was before this outcome for,
yeah,
obviously.
Yeah.
I would've talked to you before that.
And I said,
no,
because my thought before the fight when I talked to shop shop and I would talk
on the phone,
he said,
what do you think's going to happen?
I think,
I think he's,
I think Allister doesn't make it out of the first round.
We went over all the Times Alistair's been stopped.
That's a big factor.
It was a big factor isn't it?
More than 10 times.
More than 10 times in MMA I think it was,
what was it like 12 times 13 times in MMA and then three or four times in
kickboxing as well.
Once that analogy,
is there any truth to it?
It's almost like a peanut butter jar or something.
The first time you open it you got to get out a towel and put over it and tried
really hard to,
to open that lid and then after that it's a little easier and then it's a little
easier until eventually you do it enough and you can just spin it off.
Just flick it,
you know,
while he's in the flick at stage,
but it doesn't matter.
That punch would knocked him out when he was 20.
Oh yeah though knocked anyone out.
That hunch was in marketing tour.
Roy Nelson,
either either those guys and the way he threw it,
it was like a leg like from the thigh and then whipping that arm with the whole
body behind it.
Just full torque.
I mean it had everything.
It had all the power.
I was a little skeptical of the oil.
It was probably from listening to Brendon,
but talk about the punching power.
Uh,
you know,
well who else has Mark Hunt headed and has cro cop kicked it and everything
else.
And then all of a sudden once you see that punch,
like he,
he's,
he sealed the deal dude.
Ivy Calm boy's hand and it's like holding hands with a fucking cinder block.
Let's see that again.
Boom.
See how he like comes up from the thigh and the arm whips up look this way.
Oh my goodness.
And he's an easy,
as he's punching,
he's moving in position to punch a second time.
Then he Hammerfest some ways out bone.
Thank goodness he got in there.
He certainly,
I mean,
the referee got in as quick as he could,
but he certainly could have not hit him while he was down.
He was out cold.